there's a good chance we're gonna have a
female president in 2016
occurred this hillary Clinton women
apparently she's gonna run for president
that on everythang
and as we are doing our big a
spectacular show this week I want to
talk about why
gays love Hillary we were just talking
about why gays
sorted don't love barbara walters but
gays love
freakin Hillary clinton everyday lives
here they just a huge
fundraiser for the her at the abbey here
in West Hollywood
kinda gays were there she's getting all
the money gays gays voted
far more for her in 2008 than they did
for Barack Obama
what is it about Hillary and the gay we
know I think it's
it's a mutual appreciation because my
first gay pride parade was 2005 New York
City
in in the world that gay rights like
that was a lifetime ago that was a very
different world than where we're at now
yeah and she was marching in a parade
yeah and I he was senator from New York
yet
and I was like so impressed like there
she was with her rainbow flag
and so I think part of the reason why we
love her is because
she supports us so a.m. now every day
like Sir
by the way yeah there's something I
don't hide link here and I personally in
good conscience can't vote for another
clinton or bush I just simply will not
do interest we left England for a reason
and I don't think
that families I've never had anyone in
my family that was president have you
guys
not yet yes I'm pretty sure they don't
need more about you know any good that
we're just gonna Boolean 2026 I
so I just got no I don't know where
Obama that really thickening the
worshipping at these people
I do you think she's gonna suffer in a
weird way from every democrat 2016 is
gonna be for gay rights right i mean it
in the party platform
so in a weird way she's gonna lose a
little gay support because gays
won't have to vote at the democratic
gays in the primaries won't have to vote
on gay issues
the following I do she gets on your team
because she gave you gonna get it either
she's gonna get you get here it is
simply because
above her history and you know I in I
with that the 2005 pride parade it might
have been seven at the time I'm just
getting for that matter but
I remember her speech a thirty-minute
speech she gave at the UN
yeah and that was also very progressive
I believe that was 2010 11
Radha and and and I was like that ball
the because
she speaking to these countries that we
mentioned earlier that are very
conservative and actually
have a lot that persecute gay people and
I so I think gave them I her because
cover the commonest that the people give
this story
to yet and she would be she would be the
first female president and I
in I think like people for better ways
that people people
that's part of it we at Sparta the kinda
amor and in
that she's just so credible up to this
article so we're talking about with the
view but do you guys think that if there
was a game male
that had the exact same resume
I guess that would be tough because she
was first lady but if there was a gay
male who had the same exact
in terms of voting record and being pro
gay and all that
that the gays would embrace that person
I think the gays
war okay right now I'm gonna get yelled
at me that way while
I am NOT an umbrella well now
amongst us boy as we all know that
there's plenty of segregation
discrimination it within the gay
community as well someone get the keys
to that something is going to not
someone's gonna one after the top or
bottom thing and have an opinion about
that
I think I is sad to say I don't know if
the gay community with fully back gay
candidate I think we have to look at
that gay candidates are the gay a
congressman the case enters a curly Rd
in office and see what that kinda voting
record has been like but
yeah unfortunate we're just pick you her
at the door yeah I don't think there's
something about
in and I don't know how best to say this
but
that league not all game and enjoy
seeing
other game in sixty to hear what you do.
so OK to apply to roll over there that
happens that Lake
where the they're very quick to cut
other game and out yeah
so that's what I was talking about with
that you think we're so what do you
think that about because I do think I'd
absolutely think if there was a good
openly gay
the candidate running for president they
had the same exact platform is Hillary
the gays would not be into him and I i
don't know what the answer is I
it's really interesting but on a micro
level you guys are gay YouTube urs
I mean don't you get plenty of hate from
the gay community yeah more heat from
the gay community than from
the straight community a yeah edges I
and I don't know doing your own little
world what do you
what do you make that at I think it's a
it's its a
very complex question and I think I
don't know I don't know what the easy
answers but I think what I've seen as a
gay man are very
kinda quick to cut each other down that
Drake
in and I think that's not something that
just happens in the gay world I think it
happens with women seeing other women
succeed
I'm heard this from my friends a and as
I think it's like a phenomenon that
happens and marginalized communities
yeah I it's not it's not a good look I
but it's heavenly
when it is over but to look for in a row
10 yeah you agree with that
I do I think it's just a projection have
our own insecurities and the thing that
we had to deal with
during are coming out process and it in
its sometimes it's difficult to be happy
for other people when it comes to to
their success and I was gonna say
if you wanna project the public opinion
on up
potential gay presidential candidate you
can just look at them a gay celebrities
now every public gave
celebrity entertainment usually a can be
a little bit of a lightning rod for
controversy even Anderson Cooper who is
pretty as the No as they come
people are dumb people hate and we're
talking about just the gays
right